Salut ! je viens de me lever
Et aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo un peu particulière.
J'ai vraiment la tête du mec qui se lève...
Aujourd'hui, je vais tenter un vrai vlog
C'est pas un mental vlog. C'est juste un vlog
Donc, il n'y aura pas de tour ou de mentalisation sur quelqu'un.
Forcément, il faut quelque chose  d'un petit peu intéressant à vous faire voir.
J'ai été contacté il y'a quelques jours par l'émission de Stéphane Bern, "Comment ça va bien"
Ils avaient vu mes vidéos, les astuces, les Mental Vlog, les tours que je fais aux gens.
Je me rapproche beaucoup trop de cette caméra !
Donc, l'équipe de tournage débarque aujourd'hui à 16h30 à la maison,
et je vous garde avec moi.
J'ai 1 heure pour me raser, prendre une douche, me coiffer, et j'espère pouvoir vlogguer leur venue.
Je vais essayer de garder leurs lumières, mais je crois qu'ils s'en apercevront...
Est-ce que tu peux me filmer pendant que ...
Journaliste: Fabien vous nous dites plein de choses, mais
vous imaginez bien que les téléspectateurs et surtout les télespectatrices se disent:
"comment je peux faire pour stimuler ma mémoire ?"
"Est-ce que ce garçon, a des trucs pour nous ?"
Journaliste: Avez vous des "trucs"
Alors, oui il y'a pleins d'astuces, à appliquer au quotidien
Par exemple,  je suis sûr que souvent vous avez du mal à retenir un prénom et l'associer à un visage.
Erwan: Carrément !
Il existe des techniques pour faire ça,
Déja, quand quelqu'un vous dit son prénom, il faut le regarder dans les yeux
Et, immédiatement après, répéter le prénom, comme ça, il refait un tour par notre oreille,
notre cerveau, dans la mémoire à court terme
et, immédiatement après on associe une image mentale pour fixer ça.
Par exemple, vous vous appelez Erwan, je vous ai imaginé avec Erwan Mcgregor.
Comme ça, en vous imaginant avec cet acteur. J'ai une image un peu drôle
Qui va longtemps me marquer. Ca va créer un faux souvenir dans ma mémoire
Et dès que je vais vous voir, je vais penser à Erwan McGregor, le prénom Erwan, et donc
Je me souviens de votre prénom: Erwan
Erwan: donc ce sont des associations d'idées avec un circuit de la mémoire qu'on imprègne
Exactement !
On a presque fini. Ca fait 7h qu'ils sont à la maison, tout ça pour 1 minute, je crois
Non ! Ca fait 1h30, c'est vraiment cool ! J'espère que ça va vous plaire.
Ah ! Comment ils parlent... Comme les "d'jeuns"
Erwan: Je souffre mais silencieusement...
C'est beau ! J'ai vu comment tu prenais soin de tes équipes, je te comprends, c'est ouf !
Et voilà, fin de tournage, j'ai hâte que vous découvriez les images, directement sur France 2.
Rendez vous, demain, 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog, Ciao !